I went to a friend's Premiere one time
where they did a q a and there were more
people on stage than the audience I've
seen those too he's like we should leave
and I'm like I'm never leaving I'm
involved that's how a lot of those
pretentious mini film festivals are yeah
yeah they don't even have enough of
their own friends to watch their movies
and people are just getting up and
leaving while while they're like oh yeah
well you know we had a great idea and we
decided to and people just squeaking
through their seats
[Music]
thank you
so this is going to be a feel-good story
for for a change how about some good
news yeah I don't know how to react to
it we got the dancers always hosting the
show making us feel bad about ourselves
especially Anthony I know man how come
he has to [__] do that to us even
Ryan and I do love you but yesterday
dude you're like this kid got drowned or
something and I'm like Jesus here we go
dancers are like some of the most
negative people in the world this guy no
it's just my algorithm is [__] because
I look up one baby dying and now that's
all I get Darkness Darkness surrounding
I feel like dancers go on the dark web
every day dancers go on the dark web
every single day every single day you
know what happens too when Ryan probably
on Ryan's computer if you look up baby
dad it's all pink links every link is
pink everything only every single one
yeah he's clicked on every single one of
them are
his ads are [__] up no it's already
just suggesting products to buy it's not
even news anymore bone socks off
there's no Taylor Swift or t-swift yeah
I love Taylor Swifty's here are we
swifties or no I don't I don't have any
of her songs downloaded but it's around
so much that I feel like I know all the
songs I could tell you this I was very
neutral before and then I saw her tiny
desk performance oh was it good it was
really good and then so like love Tony
the fact that she writes her own music
and the way she carries uh like her in
between banter and how she has like a
like the almost like the the the
narrative for or like the movement for
all like the songs that she plays and
then like it just feels very authentic
and I really really I think she's in our
artist an amazing artist you just can't
even [__] any artist that can make me
feel like they're fan base like for
example she makes me feel like a blonde
uh 13 year old white girl yeah yeah I
think they did their job yeah like
Beyonce makes me feel like a strong
independent woman yeah that is fierce
and ready to uh battle Lord husband
cheating stay together with them yeah
yeah and then and then work my job and
be like I don't need no man because I
got a lot of money anyway like that's
base and then it makes me want to go buy
Louis but Tom person and then show
everybody yeah I like it when a girl has
not just a pretty face and a nice butt
but she can sing good too yeah that's
the best she's here she's here for so
fine she's doing like five nights in a
row yeah Taylor Swift yeah dude not just
a nice ass that's what I say about it
it's causing earthquakes so check this
out so she's um she's out of her concert
I'm gonna turn the brightness up but not
like Anthony would if there's a black
person on the street
and she he did that yesterday yeah he
did that so he did oh I saw this wait
this is Kobe Bryant's daughter uh very
sweet she comes up gives Kobe Bryant's
daughter her hat and gives her a big old
hug oh this gives her a kiss on a cheek
and a hug cute that's awesome wait
doesn't she isn't she a part of her
dance team now
oh wait no no no never mind I'm I'm I'm
getting it mixed up with uh Blue Ivy
very very young oh and you know what
else I like about her she's a [__]
gangster too
um
what was it there was like a label right
that owned all her music oh yeah and
it's so for her she was like well if
they own all my Masters or not willing
to release it I want to own my own music
so she just went and re-recorded all the
songs started from which is [__] like
it could be 10 albums and like what 12
15 songs per album and to hit all the
ad-libs all the like there's so much
[__] work that goes into recording
music but isn't it copyrighted how did
she re-record her own music and then
they didn't get a copyright strike by
YouTube well I don't know she probably
has a [__] Studio connects or
something yeah she probably gotta figure
it out but that's a gangster ass move
because a lot of people would just throw
up the White Flag we've seen so many
that's the first I've heard of anyone
doing that yeah they'll just go ah [__]
it there's nothing I can do for her
she's like nah there's another way there
has to be they didn't she
single-handedly take us out of the
recession because she was helping us
with with all these ticket sales
concerts crushing it her concert her
ticket sales one of my clients bought
some like on Thursday they said they
bought like I think a eleven to twelve
hundred dollars a pop and that was for
like some nosebleeds I've never even
heard of artists selling out like six
days in the same yeah usually it's like
one or it's like two or three nights
yeah she makes like 2.3 million in just
for Merch for each concert she's going
from like Thursday to lunch I think
Monday or Tuesday dude that's how many
[__] days
that place is what 78 and everyone there
is paying [__] two thousand dollars a
park even but do you think swifties are
getting a ticket every single day so
they can watch your six days straight
some people probably doing that yeah
some people probably follow the tour
like there's people that do [__] like
that for uh but she's not just doing it
here she's doing it everywhere
there's like insane [__] masculine
dudes in the Crowd Oh yeah they're
they're her groupies dude I saw Aaron
Rodgers quarterback [__] Hall of
Famer feature Hall of Famer he was in
the crowd dude you know when he's
warming up you know what he's listening
to I mean it's because she makes all of
us feel like a Junior High girl yeah a
good show is a good show man like and
and that's gonna be top production her
music's just amazing like writing wise
if you're a music nerd you can
appreciate it yeah it's good everybody
can like it I haven't really listened to
any of her albums I don't download any
of them listen to the tiny desk oh
listen I mean it's just her just turning
the piano on a guitar but like first
form of music you could put butts and
seats like that for that much like
obviously what you have is way crazier
than anybody what's the last concert you
bought tickets for besides Bad Bunny
um
that's a good question you went to see
Bad Bunny this is I saw scissor oh it
was really good huh who's that she's uh
just like an R B artist she's very
popular we're gonna go see Kali uchis at
the Hollywood Bowl yeah I've never been
to the Hollywood Bowl for for a concert
like that some mosquitoes get bit and
[__] that's cool yeah you do get bit a
lot yeah yeah that's I'm cool with that
but yeah Taylor Swift is freaking
popping off my freaking stupid the
second Studio I sold is now a Taylor
Swift pop-up Studio really they
redesigned all the sets to be Taylor
swift-based oh whoa yeah so they Oliver
like you know heirs tour like kind of uh
it like showcases all of her past like
work the studio got remodeled so that
all of her different like albums and
music videos it looks like that that's
very smart of the new owner it's really
smart what a move Victorian General has
been on a huge decline right like the
last big group yeah like live events in
general yeah it's been John Stamos and
the Beach Boys and then now you got
Phillip and Taylor Swift coming out
because John Stamos joined the Beach
Boys if you guys heard about that did he
really are you [__] kidding me John
John Stamos is in the Beach Boys wait
like Uncle Jesse singing
it's Jesse of Jesse and the Rippers
Jessica the Rippers dude yeah it was him
and uh it's his band in the initial
rippers yeah yeah but nobody nobody
talks about tourism anymore you ever
heard about anybody talking about tour I
only found out about about the Beach
Boys and John Stamos the last tour I
heard about that what made news was Matt
Rice Comedy Tour really yeah oh [__]
well people golden Coachella and then
like massives and then they'll do like
well 88 Rising which is
that's not one group yeah it's not a
tour no you're right it's not a tour and
that's when's the last time you heard
about a tour that everyone's like gotta
go to the see that [__] bad bunnies tour
bad Bunny's tour is pretty [__] bad
dude that's true in Latin music you
don't we don't hear about those but
those are the biggest freaking things
bro and because he was going from
United States and he was doing in
Central America he was going everyone
all of those countries
did you guys ever follow artists that
hardcore though where you would like go
to their tour no
but I wouldn't like
follow the tour no I accidentally went
to a Carly Rae Jepsen concert one time
how did you accidentally I was like I
was at Universal CityWalk with this
[__] ticket in my hand
what
he bought it
yeah friends the night before wake up
with a [__] ticket about him at the
university did you like it and I'm
wearing her shirt so when you get
blackout drunk you go to a concert you
even bought a merch yeah I'm wearing her
shirt yeah hoodie no no I was I was
actually there already it was like me
and my friends and then we just heard
like like something started we're like
what the [__] going on and we go over
to that area and like there's a Carly
Rae Jepsen like you know how like when
you're when an artist is first coming
out
they like tore them all over malls and
[__] yeah it was like that oh cool but
like it was when Call Me Maybe had just
come out like just oh so this is like oh
wow yeah yeah yeah oh dope and then I
remember being in the crowd and I'm such
an [__]
um you had cold I was like playing Call
Me Baby nobody [__] cares play call
me baby the whole time oh she was doing
her like B-side track she's doing all
her [__] and it was so boring it was
so boring but I was like you gotta do
call me maybe and then she wouldn't and
then I think she did this just to
[__] [__] with me a little bit she
left and then did call me maybe but when
she did call me maybe people went nah
everyone lost their minds yeah dude that
that's was that on the radio at the time
yeah it was like the biggest song oh so
she just started that was such a huge
freaking song it was a huge song Insane
yeah that's a song where you're like I
don't get it but I'm on board I love it
yeah
yeah I feel like live shows and all
that's coming back I think people are
warming back up to like being normal
again it's
because like Margot Rob I mean the
[__] Barbie and Oppenheimer they had
a huge turnout during the week the the
opening weekend and then they're saying
like oh wow people are going back to the
movies now they thought it was that I
really liked the movie experience so it
would suck to see like because I think
for a while they're like really scared
because the numbers just kept dwindling
doing and doing and I love the movie
experience do you think that like these
bespoke kind of artsy theaters would be
able to survive if movie going wasn't
popular for the average person hell no
like Alamo like Alamo Theater it's like
a lot of like Cinema lovers yeah it's
Gotta Be families It's gotta be family
yeah that's what I was like I was like
thinking oh maybe they'll always have
their core audience but maybe that's not
true if ArcLight closed dude's gone yeah
because ArcLight probably had the most
like Cinema lovers that you could
possibly get and they aren't glad it's
gone yeah yeah Cinerama Dome gone yeah
really oh wow holy [__] I thought Alan
will survived because of the drinks and
the food and stuff yeah it's a little
bit like a it's like a hipster idea it's
more of an experience yeah but even then
that that makes their profit margin like
they have to make more money to like the
ArcLight business model was really to do
easy to duplicate though like all these
theaters now all of them you can choose
your seats before all of them don't play
like you know like the stupid
commercials whatever they just go
straight to the previews like a lot of
them just changed but you know where
they [__] up
they're missing one element they need
the announcer oh yeah that guy's cool
there's always that one guy with the
curly hair yep and then they do the
announcement I do like that sure we just
want to check on your sound experience
make sure everything's real chill I love
those dudes has anybody ever done a
prank where at the end of a random film
they make a fake q a and none of these
people worked out the movie oh my God
that'll be we're gonna get a q a from
some of the guys that worked on
production some of the crew Colleen
gaffer I definitely went to a friends I
went to a friend's Premiere one time
where they did a q a and there were more
people on stage than the audience oh
I've seen those two though those are
really out I loved every second because
like we should leave and I'm like I'm
never leaving I'm involved but but
that's how a lot of those that's how a
lot of those pretentious mini film
festivals are yeah yeah they don't even
have enough of their own friends to
watch their movies [__] rough dude
and people are just getting up and
leaving while while they're like oh yeah
well you know we had a great idea and we
decided to and people just [__]
squeaking through their seats
[Laughter]
nobody gives a [__]
like you think they were bro
nobody gives them but that's tough oh
yeah that hurts my feelings it feels
good
yeah I feel like all the movies that
cater to just families and entertain
them and the normal general public Mass
Market they always win yeah pretentious
artists always [__] lose
because even the concession stands like
just the regular snacks crushes yeah
everyone tries to be fancy and [__] like
people just want [__] gummy bears
wagyu corn dog yeah they just want a
[__] hot dog like just some normal
[__] yeah people try to go so fancy when
I just saw barbie too my buddy's like
I'll buy the tickets you get the
concessions right and I was like okay
cool no problem it's like even and then
when I got the concessions I'm like
[__] spending 55 and I'm like this
son of a [__]
tickets are 15 bucks you [__] good
man that was a 50 sausage they're good
they're good too because the drink is
like oh you like a small and it's like
it's a medium large and it's like a two
cent difference for the large so you
gotta upgrade is 41 obese no they only
this is like small Yeah medium and large
and to upgrade it's like three cents
they're like they're like like a
18-wheeler center caps for the wheels
yeah yeah I do like movie theaters where
the slurpee machine is outside so you
can just refill whatever you want yeah
[Music]
foreign